[Applause]
hello everyone
I'd like to show their game that was
played yesterday at the 52nd kappa
blanka Memorial between basel ii von
Schuch and sam Shanklin luckily logic is
a well-known figure in the chess world
and Stan shank and if you don't know who
is he's an American Grandmaster a very
strong player he was a part of the
United States team last year that won
gold at the Olympics
the first time in four years alongside
Shekhar Nakamura
Fabiana Caruana was also and the Ray
Robson so my trick is white and the
shangkun's is black let's see the game
okay we have d4 Knight a sip c4 e6
height of 3 is 6
the King's Indian the 10g 3 which would
be 4 which would be to assemble treaties
Bishop d7 93 d7 22 black castle this is
the G 296 Castle v5c d5 Knight before
Queen 8 or black recaptures with the
knight on d5 and now rook F to D 1 we
need gentle monster change Queens and
luckily applied protects only 8 nice the
e5 and here stands a template C 5 and
here eventual this interesting idea that
proved to be
could be very interesting and very good
he takes on c5-b dxe5 and is threatening
critic so black has recaptured black
captors with the bishop rotate the C 1
plus a 2 CH and I might be 5 things like
a peculiar move he is attacking the a7
phone but what you're going to do after
black plays a 6 which Sam does and he
nearly wanted to find this interesting
idea Brook takes d5 now if black
captures the Knights the one who will
simply recapture I mean capture the pawn
on d5 with the rook if sam takes his
work with his working c8 then 96 is
coming and if which was played and it
detects with the pawn on d6 then nice 96
attack both works and the bishop so the
only move is reflects e5 and now nice d6
attacking the rook the bishop and the
phone on f8 so here
Hanson played with the v8 and Evancho's
took the next step so here he has a a
pawn for the exchange
so let's see what he had in mind
Franklin goes Bishop to a 8e for 9 to 6
7 f3 cementing those pawns work to f8
Bishop to e3 rook to c2 now 95 rook to
d8 Bishop F 1 night 2 e 8 Bishop to d3
given up some response
Knight to c4 attacking the rook giving
up another pawn and obviously takes b6
pinning the night okay so here we can
see how blacks position is a bit
complicated to play rook to a for work
the c1 corrupted be for king of two with
the b5 Bishop to f1 rugby eight and now
Knight to d7 okay so here eventually
protecting the fish maybe six
he is also attacking the work on b8
Black has three possible ways rock to
see a rock the DF and with to b7
Samuel applied rook to b8 I when I first
firstly by myself
why not rook c8 this way he goes once
again under the pin of the bishop
although okay because the rook c8 he in
directly under the pin of this broken c1
I checked the position on the computer
and the best move is worth the b7 but
that just looks weird you know walking
around business and leaving the last
rank so similar play to rip the DX and
now tonight's the Eve I
this opens I discovered the attack from
Division f1 to work to b5 so that has to
be a rest work to be two checks into g1
depending upon on h2 and our Bishop
missile given up the beasts a bunch of
takes on c7 rock to see a and now we
want to find a way to keep your feet
nice and III rook to d2 and now keeping
the knife but if I find business before
and now the pin doesn't work anymore so
here we have it will take foxy 15022
group d1 before this is the c6 attacking
the knight Knight to e5 we should be
quiet finger to Knight to f6 h4 h 6o
black has the rook but the white think
they have too much material nice to h5
Bishop e2 e2 rook to be 1/2 for a 2x6 in
d3
rooks h1h 5 9 8 7 s 4 nice s 6 request 3
attacking the rook rook to be 1 and
Knight d5 and here hang on resigned
there isn't there is no way to defend
the d6 pawn and there are no checks
there are no there's nothing black and
white will slowly but surely win this so
this is a nice swing by a nice win by a
van chopped this was round five of the
fifty second cattle block memorial here
we have the standings after round five
Avantika is leading with three and a
half points out of five followed by
occasions a secure and cordova Emilio
Samuel Shanklin who just lost 40 Suarez
and pure room and pronounce this guy's
name sorry and the event should also one
last year and this is I think he wants
seven times the Casablanca memorial and
if he went this long this will be his
eighth title cut the pepper monkey
Memorial Tournament so yeah we'll see
how it goes I'm always interested to see
Jackie played he's a great guy and I
don't know it doesn't get any like it
it's that big of a deal for him to win
this tournament you know because on a
good day one can beat almost not almost
he can beat anyone he can beat Megan
scoffs and twice in one day
so to say so yes that was the game I
hope you enjoyed it see you soon